TED WARNER: So
thank you so much.
So I guess the question
that I am dying to ask
is, how did you find the
people who are in this?
DRAPER SHREEVE:
I've been doing yoga
for about 14 years at The
Center on 13th Street, which
is kind of a crossroads
of the world, especially
for the gay community.
And meeting all of
these people there,
I was really struck by
the incredible diversity
of the community and the
people that go there.
And it kind of
forced me to think
about what it was that I
was really interested in,
and it was people.
What's more interesting
than people?
And there are so many different
kinds of people that go there.
And through friends that
I had there-- teachers,
other people that I met--
we met friends of friends,
friends of friends of
friends, and so on.
And I started to become very
excited about a canvas, a very
large canvas that
I could create.
And I was excited by
the diversity of people.
And I love making
a movie where you
have a state senator
and a porn director
and a street kid and
an 81-year-old painter.
I found that exciting.
So basically from there.
That was kind of a
starting point, I guess.
TOWNES COATES:
And it really did.
I mean, when I
came into it-- that
was probably a year into your
doing sit-down interviews
with people.
Draper had done a number of
sit-down interviews with people
from really across the spectrum.
And part of that was seeing
how people were on camera.
And part of that
was getting stories,
seeing where people came from.
And I think one of the
lovely things about this film
is that it's not
Manhattan within a very
certain prescribed boundary.
It really is people from all
across, from the five boroughs,
and really a remarkable
mix of people
who might not have ways
of crossing otherwise.
And the people who ended
up in the final film
are truly remarkable.
And there were a lot of
really remarkable people
who went through the process.
But these were the
ones ultimately
that he decided to follow
in this very intimate way.
And it takes a big commitment
to be in a film like this.
HENRY CHALFANT: Just
doing all those interviews
was kind of like auditioning,
because you found out
the people who were really
the most giving and generous
with themselves.
And I think that's who we found.
It was very profound
through this process.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
It was a challenge
to find a balance of
people too, I think,
because we found so
many incredible people.
People are still coming
up to us and saying,
you know, I got this
cousin in the Bronx.
Have you got everybody
for your movie yet?
Because he's really,
really interesting.
And we're like,
yeah, we've got it.
But it was trying
to get a balance.
That was difficult.
TED WARNER: So I also
want to encourage people
from the audience.
If you want to ask
a question, there's
microphones on either side.
HENRY CHALFANT: Jump in.
TED WARNER: And yeah,
feel free to jump in.
Sure.
HENRY CHALFANT:
There's microphones.
TED WARNER: You can
use-- well, either way.
That's fine.
TOWNES COATES: There's
an audience microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
this is wonderful.
What a wonderful way
to spend an afternoon.
Thank you, Mr. Director.
I sat here very moved,
because I'm 45 years old.
And it is inconceivable
that a documentary exploring
identity and challenges
and personal existence as
in gayness would ever not
include AIDS in my lifetime
as a backbone.
Any other documentary
would have had
it-- we had mentioned briefly
with Tee and her sisters.
But the idea that now that that
imminent threat, that bullet
to the head, is
diminished, we're
left with the same issues
of depression and suicide
and glory and
family and all that.
It was just fascinating
to see that.
But there are also issues
of power and identity.
Did you have any struggle as
a gay white man commandeering
these stories from people
who are facing challenges,
as you filmed them eating,
which is incredibly intimate?
A lot of food.
But did you ever since
anyone editing themselves?
Or maybe the opposite happened.
They wanted to share,
because this was a--
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Well-- is this on?
HENRY CHALFANT: No,
that's a different one.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Let me first say,
we realized from
the very beginning
we couldn't represent everyone.
[LOUD FEEDBACK]
HENRY CHALFANT: Just go.
DRAPER SHREEVE: We couldn't
represent everyone,
and then we didn't really try.
And then I think other
films, other documentaries,
have explored AIDS, gay
marriage, because they're
whole worlds.
AUDIENCE: My point
is, it was a relief
to see "Queer City" can
happen without the--
DRAPER SHREEVE: Without
that particular narrator.
AUDIENCE: --"I have to go
take my meds, la la la la la,"
which I do daily, by the way.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Well,
for many of us--
it was your
generation-- it's true.
You thought, would we ever
not have that in our lives?
So that's part of what we
wanted to do with this project,
is make a modern film
about now and about looking
into the future, thinking
about the future.
And things are changing
very, very rapidly.
Talking about the
different-- do I
feel as a white man-- this
whole project for all of us
was and is such a journey and
a really wonderful journey.
Because when we started
this, you really
don't know what
you're going to find.
I was interested-- as Henry
said from the very beginning,
we would do these talking
heads with people.
And it would give you kind
of a 101 of their story.
And it helps us gauge
how complicitous
they would be with the
project to [INAUDIBLE].
But yeah, it was
a great adventure.
I knew nothing about making porn
movies and Haitian food, which
I love, by the way.
And just-- yeah,
all kinds of things.
HENRY CHALFANT: I
think of lot of credit
goes to Draper for his
style of engaging people.
You don't come on as a
person who's going to,
well, let's get the
story, and then you'll
never see them again.
There's a development of a
certain kind of friendship.
And I don't think
you can-- we tend
to think that, oh, people are
going to be very close to us.
But it's amazing how
much people really
feel the need and the
desire to tell their story.
And I think that
just obliterates
all kinds of racial class,
gender lines all the time.
TOWNES COATES: And
Henry, if you don't know,
Henry Chalfant is perhaps
best known career-long
for "Style Wars," which was
really the landmark New York
film about the graffiti
artists in New York,
when no one else was
even looking at this
and considering
this as fine art.
And I think Draper certainly
turned to Henry's wisdom a lot
about immersing yourself
in other people's worlds
and not only helping--
the comfort on both sides.
And one of the things we found--
and one of the characters
in particular who was a
great talker-- at some point,
I said, the fact is
nobody has ever asked her
her story before.
She's got so much story to
tell, and no one has ever asked.
And she sees this as
a great opportunity
to get her history
to leave her mark.
And it is a great
opportunity on both sides.
And I think all of the
people who participated
have, in retrospect, been happy
they did it and are incredibly
grateful to Draper for providing
them the forum to do it.
DRAPER SHREEVE: I
also want to thank
my producers-- Townes Coates
and Henry Chalfant and our story
consultant, Chris Bram--
who gave me so much support
and freedom to pursue all this.
So thank you.
HENRY CHALFANT: And
I want to shout out
to the aesthetic and artistic
gifts of our director, who
made this so appealing
to watch, the choices
that he made as editor
and as director.
Really made a beautiful film.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Thank you,
and Henry was one of the DPs.
HENRY CHALFANT: Yeah.
If you want to know
what executive producer
means, in this
instance, it was-- well,
we bought half a camera.
And we went out and
started shooting.
That's the most
fun part of it all.
And of course,
you're always trying
to learn the new equipment,
different things.
And you make mistakes
and everything.
But that's how we began.
And then, of course,
you've got to think
about raising money after that.
What's interesting,
too-- you asked
about the straight white
man and access and the food,
the eating, at Tee's house.
Draper had the brilliant idea.
Our DP was an old
friend of mine,
who's a straight white man.
But he's a very engaging guy and
is a wonderful cinematographer.
And we got him on board.
Around the time,
we were thinking
of doing this dinner
at Tee's home.
And Draper said, let's just
leave Mike in there with them.
And we went off for an hour
or two and just let them go.
And it was a tiny
little room, as you saw.
And so he had no
trouble making everybody
feel at home in that room.
AUDIENCE: A couple things.
First of all, I
love documentaries.
And this really was
an extraordinary one,
it seemed to me.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was fully engaged.
In particular, the balance
between the interview
and then the actual scenes.
You just never were bored.
I mean, you just never-- yeah.
As a matter of fact,
it made me think
that if there was
one kind of film
that we could have from the
16th century about people
who we are absent from most
of history-- a film like this.
The question I had
is simply this.
There are so many
wonderful scenes in it.
But the one that I know a
lot of people won't forget
is the one on the bicycle where
the porn star and her friend--
I mean, the narrative
going along with the--
but how did that come about?
[LAUGHTER]
DRAPER SHREEVE: Well,
first of all, I shot it.
And Henry was driving the car.
And with all of these people,
we were always looking
for excuses for B-roll
footage, because we
had these great interviews.
But you can't just sit
there and listen to them--
you know, what's your life like?
What do you do?
And I knew that Mr. Pam and her
current boyfriend at that time,
Rafael, were big bike riders.
And I thought, they'd be fun.
We can get you on your bikes.
Would you like to do that?
And they said, yeah.
So we started out.
We're uptown.
They're on their bikes.
And the further we came
downtown, more of their clothes
came off.
And by the time we got
to Christopher Street,
they were down to
bra and slip and--
AUDIENCE: And that
was just them?
DRAPER SHREEVE:
That was just them.
And you noticed they were--
TOWNES COATES: And in fairness,
the same thing happens with me.
[LAUGHTER]
DRAPER SHREEVE: Yeah.
That's right.
But they started
out on two bikes.
And then around Christopher
Street, she had a flat tire.
And that didn't
stop them at all.
They hopped on the other.
And by that time, it
was just a circus.
And we thought,
we're getting this.
And we're driving around.
There's a lot of outtakes.
We couldn't include everything.
Tourists were-- they were
excited and flummoxed and--
TOWNES COATES: Why
they come to New York.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Right, yeah.
They love that.
It was good.
I'm glad you liked it.
AUDIENCE: I love the film.
I think it's really beautiful.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
surprised that it was.
Two things.
One thing, I really
noticed that what
seemed like one of the
big subthemes of movie
that emerged was really
how the cities changed
so much-- like the city
itself, not just Queer City.
But it felt like
so much of this was
about how the world of this
city is changing so much.
And I was wondering if you
had any thoughts about that.
My other question would be
also about the use of music.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Well, for those of us
who have lived here a long time,
it certainly has changed a lot.
Some of that is
reflected in the film.
I don't know.
Were there parts
in particular that
made you think of
old New York or--
AUDIENCE: You know, sometimes
they would just pass places.
They'd be like, well,
that's not there.
It's changed very much anymore.
And also, one of the things that
all the people had in common
is that most of them were
not wealthy New Yorkers.
And I thought that was also
a really interesting thing
about it.
So that's also what
make me think about it,
and thinking how these
people-- or all of us-- who
are not in certain echelons
will be squeezed out eventually.
So I guess there was
a melancholy or almost
a wastefulness about how
much longer this world
will be there, which made me
think about the changing city,
I guess.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Well, these are a lot
of stories that I didn't think
you would normally hear at all.
And a lot of people
that are very
comfortable-- I don't always
know that their lives are
that interesting.
Maybe in some respect.
But these people, they
spoke to me on some level.
I thought they were fascinating.
But for a lot of
them, especially
as it goes further
and further into it,
they are struggling here.
And it's not just
their orientation.
It's many, many things
that impact them.
You ask about the music.
The music is by Eef Barzelay,
who is an Israeli composer.
I found him through
his agent in LA.
And I wrote a letter
kind of explaining
what I was looking for.
And I didn't want to
use synthesized music.
I wanted acoustic.
And I wrote this
very long letter.
These are examples
of what I like,
blah-blah-blah, blah-blah-blah.
And she came back
with two people,
and he was the first one.
And it turns out he
lives in Nashville,
which is where I'm from.
And I thought, wow,
this is interesting.
So we went there to
record the music.
And it was very interesting.
He's a great guy.
He's very talented.
And he wrote all of this for it.
And that's him singing, and
he scored all this as well.
TOWNES COATES: And I think
there was a sensitivity toward--
and I think part of Draper--
musical vision of this,
was something that
was very rhythmic.
Because you have that
rhythm of the city
accompanying these
personal stories.
DRAPER SHREEVE: Tell them about
how we found the tap dancer.
TOWNES COATES: Oh, right.
And the tap dancer
and the drummer
that you see in some of
those interstitial shots.
And that was us walking
down the street one evening
and passing by the old
music store, which was on--
DRAPER SHREEVE: Music Inn.
TOWNES COATES: The
Music Inn, yes.
And there was a guy out
front with a piece of plywood
who was tap dancing, and he was
being accompanied by a drummer.
It was one of those--
you're just walking by,
and this is going on
in the summer night.
And we're walking past.
And of course, then I realized
that Draper is no longer
walking here and
that he's stopped
and is going back to wait
until they take a little break.
And said, could I
come back one day?
I'm doing this.
I think what you're doing is
such an interesting sound.
It really got my attention.
Could I come back
and record sound?
And they said, sure, of course.
And it progressed from
there, from recording sound
to filming them and
doing a whole recording
session of the sound
and visuals as well.
So from just taking a
break from the music store
they worked in
out on the street,
they ended up as these great New
York characters in this film.
TED WARNER: So how long
did it take to make this?
DRAPER SHREEVE: We shot on
and off for about four years.
Some of the subjects
in it were--
we had already accumulated
a lot of material on them.
And they were great, and
we wanted to use them.
And then sometimes they
just weren't available.
Tom Duane was going out of
office around that time.
And I already had
committed to have that.
I really wanted him in the film.
But we had to wait for
months to get to his office
and shoot a lot of stuff.
TOWNES COATES: And
truly, as I always say,
the average documentary is seven
years from beginning to end.
So if we came in at 5:00, we
were way ahead of the game.
HENRY CHALFANT: So true.
TED WARNER: It really
feels like these people
were telling their own story.
And I didn't see that there
was a lot of narration.
It was really just the
people talking on their own.
And I'm wondering
how much of what
happened was something
that you predicted
or that you wanted to
happen, and how much of it
was organic that happened over
the course of making the film.
DRAPER SHREEVE: It
was all organic,
because when you do
something like this,
you don't really know
what you're going to get.
And the only thing we
really had to judge by
were the initial talking
heads, the subjects,
to get a general sense of
their story and who they were
and how willing they
would to be to be in this.
And so a lot of
things-- like, we
didn't know what we
were going to get.
We would suggest a
bike ride for somebody,
and it turns into this
circus on the street, so.
TOWNES COATES: Just
in the same way
that Geoffrey had
mentioned in his interview
about working with the
Alzheimer's patients, that
became a real destination.
And that center could
not have been better.
And the families, everyone--
everyone you saw-- everyone
did their releases.
The families were very
much involved, were
perfectly willing to have
their family members involved
in this.
But that's something that
grew out of-- you know,
Geoffrey just mentioning
in the interview
that this was volunteer
work he was doing
with Alzheimer's patients.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Tee, for example--
I had no idea about her
story, about her family,
her catastrophic loss.
And I remember sitting there
when she's telling that
and hearing for the first
time that she had lost five
members of her family to AIDS.
And I'd never heard that before.
I mean, yeah.
It was a journey.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Were the
mothers of the twins
present when you were
interviewing them?
Were they, when they
were talking about--
TOWNES COATES: No, it were not.
And it's so interesting,
because Draper and I were there
together.
And the interview area was
set up down in their basement.
And I fully expected-- here we
are, like two middle-aged men.
And the mothers had-- I mean,
they'd known Draper before.
That maybe have been the
first time they both met me.
And we said, do you want to sit
in when we interview the kids
and interview the
kids separately?
And they said, no, they're fine.
And those kids were, as you
saw, incredibly self-possessed.
And they were terrific.
And the whole family
has seen-- actually,
maybe [? Leah ?]
hasn't seen it yet.
But the family has seen it.
And they loved it.
And the fact that
they have raised
those two kids to say
what's on their mind,
and they absolutely do.
DRAPER SHREEVE:
Any more questions?
TED WARNER: Well,
we thank you all.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]